فخوره اني موجوده اليوم برج الحمراء طابق
55 اطلاله جميل على مدينه الكويت كونيك
معماريه كوني شغوفه في العماره كوني اشوف
هذه المباني اللي لها تاريخ ولها ارث
معماري
تحاكي الماضي وابيها تحاكي الاطفال الجيل
القادم المعماري الصغير رحلتي بالعماره
شغف كبير وبحاول اختصره معاكم
وين ابدا ما ادري حطوا لي عنوان اليوم وما
ادري اذا انا احتاج عنوان ولا ما احتاج
عنوان ويمكن اسالكم شنو العنوان
هي رحله هي رحله وما خلصت واحتاج العنوان
مع الاطفال اللي معاي في كم طفل الحين كان
معي في رحله الاعمار
وبنين جيل قاعد يبني الديره بفكر معماري
جديد
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم هذه الصوره اللي
تشوفونها 2016
كنت احاول اقول
شنو مسؤوليتي كمعماريه يعني
الديره علمتني الجامعه علمتني كليه
العماره علمتني تخرجت معاي كتبي معاي
رساله ابي ادورها ابي اتعلم
تخرجت من الجامعه 2003 والحين عشرين
كنت ادور انا وين وشنو اقدر اعطيه وكنت
مستمره من مرحله لمرحله الى لقيت بوصله
بوصله العماره
2019 عقب ما خلصت الماجستير
بسرعه شرايش بالاطفال كانهما الجيل
المستقبل كانهم اهم المعماريين اللي ممكن
يعني
يدل الرساله اللي انت كنت ودي تكوني فيها
وانت صغيره انا ببدا بقصه كنت كاتبتها من
قبل وبحاول اختصرها لكم هنا طبعا دفتره
المعماريين دائما يعرفونها احنا ايدنا
دائما في هوايه اشياء ونحاول قد ما نقدر
نبسط العماره ومو سهل انك تبسط العماره في
كتاب ولا صفحه بس بقول لكم شغله الحين
سبحان الله على قصه واتوقع انه كل واحد
مار عليها وهو صغير
شوفوا المكعبات اللي هني شلون العفسه
واولوفر قاعدين
كان في كان في معماريه واقفه وتطالع بنيه
صغيره قاعده تحاول تلعب بالمكعبات
تركبهم فوق بعض فوق بعض فوق بعض لين طاحوا
بعدين المعماريه وقفت شويه كانت تقول كان
البنيه كانت تحاول تسوي بيت كانه قعدت
تركب شيء كانه عماره وكان سبحان الله يعني
كانه ما تدري ان هذا ممكن المكعبات تكون
بيت لها تبنيه وما يهتم
مسؤوليه المعماريه قربت من هذه الطفله
وقالت لها
اللي قاعد تسوينه العماره
اللي قاعد تسوينا عماره هذا البناء عماره
اذا كان لش دورتش ايتها الطفله الصغيره
انش تبنين هذه المكعبات وتشكلين لش بيت
صغير وتاخذين دميتك وتلعبين فيها هذه
رساله كبيره للبناء وليس الهدم والجيل
مستقبل باذن الله تعالى واعد بالبناء
والارتقاء فبديت في هذه القصه الطفله
الصغيره وما كنت ادري انها واحده من اللي
موجودين هنا ويمكن وحده اللي واقفه على
الستيج
وصلت لي الرساله انه هذا المكعبات او هذه
العفسه اللي نلقاها بغرف الاطفال ممكن
تحول هذا الطفل الصغير الى معماري او
تحوله الى
انسان واعي بمفهوم العماره واللغه
المعماريه اللي احنا فاقدينها حاليا
رسالتي كانت يعني
هذا الكتب اللي عندي وهذا
المعرفه انا بالنسبه للحين بسيطه بس للحين
قاعده اتبحر في مفهوم العماره شلون انقلها
وحتى الصوره اللي من قبل انا شايله
مسؤوليه وما ادري شايله مسؤوليه وهلا علي
مسؤوليه ولا لا شفت ابراج الكويت معناتها
وين هويتنا والهويه العربيه الكويتيه شلون
انقلها شلون شنو المسؤوليه اللي عندي شلون
اخضر الديره شلون اعمر الديره هذه ما ادري
شلون الرسمه كانت سبحان الله 2019 بدت
تزهر الفكره وبدت تطلع الفكره وبديت اوصل
لمرحله اللي هي ليش ما ابدا بالتبسيط
العماره اشوف العماره من خلال الطفل قعدت
اقول كيف يرى المباني الطفل واحنا شلون
نشوفها انا كمعماريه اشوف المباني بطريقه
مختلفه نفس ما تشوفونها هنا خريطه وستركشر
واضح الطبيب شلون يشوف العماره يشوفها كان
دقات القلب والطفل شلون يشوفها
ببساطه اللي يشوفها كانها حلاوه كان اقول
اوكي في شيء في شيء ناقص ودي اوصله
للاطفال من وين ابدا وشلون ابدا ما ادري
اهلين اهلين رحله من 2019 حسيت بالمسؤوليه
المعماريه وبلشت انطلق هذا الانطلاق هذي
احلام اطفال قاعده تنتقل معاي من مكان
لمكان ما عندي صف ما عندي مدرسه انا
متنقله مع الاطفال في رحله اعماريه معاهم
وين بنوصل ما ندري وين الطريق ما ادري بس
اهمل نقطه الانطلاقه للاعمار الحقيقي اللي
قاعد تشوفونه هنا لما اقول سرال العماره
للجميع شلون تسوينها رحت الى الصم والبكم
توصيل العماره للصم والبكم وصلت لهم
لمرحله انه يحتاجون يعرفون مفهوم العماره
شو اللي ناقص عندنا منهج معماري بسيط مبسط
شلون نبسط العماره هذه جزء من الرحله
تمشينا شويه رحنا الى المدينه الترفيهيه
العماره والترفيه مع الاطفال هل موجود
بالكويت ولا لا
ما كان موجود كانوا يشوفون اشياء بره
الكويت شلون نجيبها من خلال اطفالنا
واحلامهم وين رحنا بعد وين رحنا ايه اهلي
عمار يا كويت عندنا ورش
تحاكي التاريخ المعماري والاطفال من خلال
الاعياد الوطنيه والاحتفالات الوطنيه هم
سوينا بعض الفعاليات والورش اللي تعكس
تراثنا المعماري والكويتي وين بعد رحنا
رحنا ابراج الكويت بعد رحنا ابراج الكويت
وخذينا جوله معماريه في المكان وبالنسبه
حق الاطفال يعني ما كانوا رايحين الابراج
الكويت وما شافوها بالناحيه او المنظور
المختلف حق المدينه لما بداوا يشوفوا
المدينه مكونات المدينه
بداوا يعزمون ربعهم حق ابراج الكويت وهنا
السياحه المعماريه من خلال الاطفال قاعد
نحرك نحرك نحرك
العماره من خلال الاطفال وين بعده صلى اي
وصلنا الى المدارس سوينا تجربه خاصه مع
مدرسه بيان البيان ثنائيه اللغه
معاهم بربط الفن والعماره من هذا المنهج
من 2019 الى الان بدينا نصمم المدن
المستقبليه كل سنه وحتى بالايام الكوفيد
العماره من خلال الطفل انا كمعماريه
مسؤوليتي لما ابني مدينه عقب عشر سنين
عشرين سنه تبنى هي مو حقي حق الطفل فلما
يكون الطفل معاي في هذه الرحله العماريه
هنا احس الاعمار الحقيقي احنا قعد نبني
مدن حق عيالنا وليش عيالنا ما يكونون
معانا في هذا المدن فمن خلال الدراسات من
2019 طبعا في احلام حلوه تترجم من العماره
الى الواقع يعني واحده منهم مثلا تبي
كاندي سيتي شنو يعني كاندي ستي شنو من
مدينه الحلويات تبي شيء فيه يعني حياه
حلاوه حولناها الى مباني حقيقيه
فهذه الرحله اللي احنا بدينا فيها بس شلون
بديت بديت هذا الفيديو من البيت لا حد
يقول انه صعبه كانت تجربه الادوات اللي
عندي بالبيت بس خذيتهم واستخدمتهم هذا اول
ما تخرجت من الماجستير يا ان اكمل الجانب
الاكاديمي او اخذ تجربه خاصه من البيت
ومن هذه بعده الرحله وهنا الله يحفظهم
عيالي راح تشوفون اياديهم قلت لهم بليز
احتاجكم بالصوره معاي لانه ما ادري
بالمستقبل بتكون معي بالعماره ولا لا
والحمد لله ربع ساعه بس على ما صوروا معي
والحمد لله هذه الى حد ما من 2019 وراح
اخذكم في الرحله
[موسيقى]
طبعا شلون اترجم العماره للاطفال وشلون
اذا بنبدي في هويه معماريه عربيه حقيقيه
ومنها تنتقل الى العالميه استوعبت ان
اللغه العربيه في العماره كان فيها وايد
صعوبه يعني حتى لما اترجم
العماره لما اترجمها من المناهج اللي انا
تعلمتها ايام الجامعه الى الواقع وايد كان
صعب اخذها مني سنتين ايام كوفي 19 ايام
كورونا لاحول او اترجم العماره الى قصه
ومنتج معماري ثقافي يحاكي التاريخ ويحاكي
حلم طفل والطفل هذا الله يحفظه يعني انا
وايد احترمه لانه
متعاون
متسائل فضولي
وساعي للخير هاي الشخصيات اللي اخذت مني
سنتين على ما تكونت لله الحمد بدات تنطلق
مو بس بالقصه بدات تروح الى اماكن سياحيه
هي والطلب اللي معاي هم راحوا السعوديه
مره معاي وراحوا وكذا مكان سياحي بالكويت
ما حد يدري عنه رحنا وين رحنا المرسم الحر
اخذوا زياره راحوا الابراج الكويت معاهم
وراحوا المركز الامريكاني بعد فصارت في
رحله القصه مو بس كتاب لا الشخصيات شلون
تطلع من الكتاب وشلون تكون جزء من رحله
الاعمار مع الاطفال هذه اللوحه اذا
تشوفونها او تدفقون فيها
كيف تكون
كن انت التعمير كل واحد عندنا رساله انه
يكون التعمير اذا هني تشوفون مر عليكم
هالبيت ولا لا
منطقه من مناطق الكويت فكل القصص والصور
اللي تشوفونها هنيه في مجله ماجد بعد راح
تلقونها فتعطي رساله للطفل انه يدقق
بالتفاصيل وياخذ من هذه التفاصيل وينقلها
الى الواقع بخبرته وبافكاره نيره دور
الطفل مهم دورنا مهم وشلون احنا نكون
التعمير جسمنا التعمير كاهل
كمعماريين
كمواطنين بس شكرا جزيلا
[تصفيق]